BIG, YOU KNOW, A BIG TALL TASK
BUT I BELIEVE THAT HE IS CAPABLE
OF GETTING CLOSE TO THAT IF NOT
OVERCOMING IN.
>> WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT
LaMELO BALL AND THE GODS HAVE
GRACED US WITH HIS PRESENCE.
LaMELO BALL IS NOW JOINING US ON
THE TUESDAY SHOW.
AGAIN, 2021 ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
LaMELO, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US.
YOU WERE NAMED THE RISING STARS
LAST YEAR.
BUT THE GAME DIDN'T HAPPY.
WE DIDN'T GET TO SEE YOU AT
ALL-STAR WEEKEND.
WHAT CAN WE EXPECT FROM YOU IN
CLEVELAND THIS YEAR AS YOU GO
OUT THERE FOR ALL-STAR GAME?
>> HOPEFULLY, A SHOW.
I MEAN, GO OUT THERE AND HAVE
FUN.
JUST DOING WHAT EVERYBODY IN THE
LEAGUE RIGHT NOW, SO I FEEL LIKE
IT'S GOING TO BE A GREAT TIME.
>> LaMELO, SHAQ HERE.
THREE THINGS.
ONE, I'M SO PROUD OF YOU.
TWO, CONGRATULATIONS.
AND, LASTLY YOU REMIND ME OF A
GUY WHOSE NAME IS PENNY
HARDAWAY.
WHEN HE CAME INTO THE LEAGUE HE
HAD EVERYTHING.
I ASKED PENNY WHAT DID YOU MODEL
YOUR GAME AFTER?
HE SAID MAGIC JOHNSON.
I ASK YOU WHO DO YOU MODEL YOUR
GAME AFTER?
>> MYSELF.
I TRY TO BE MYSELF FOR REAL.
I SEEN A LOT OF JAMAAL CRAWFORD
AND PENNY HARDAWAY TOO AND
MOSTLY JAMAAL CRAWFORD AND VIDEO
GAMES AND SEEING WHAT THEY WERE
DOING THERE.
I GO OUTSIDE AND TRY IT.
PRETTY MUCH THAT MY WHOLE GAME
CAME TO ME.
>> MELO, AS A BABY IN THE
FAMILY, YOU'RE THE BABY IN THE
FAMILY.
WE DON'T LACK CONFIDENCE.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU'VE GONE VIRAL
POINTING AT THE HALF-COURT LINE
PULLING UP AND SHOOTING.
SO I JUST WANT TO TELL YOU SHAQ
HAS 50 K.
IF YOU POINT AT HALF-COURT AND
HIT IT FROM THE, YOU KNOW,
HALF-COURT LINE.
>> I GOT A HUNDRED.
>> YOU GOT A HUNDRED.
I GOT A HUNDRED FOR YOU.
I JUST NEED 20%!
YOU GOT TO HIT IT, THOUGH.
>> DEFINITELY GOT TO GO FOR IT
NOW.
ILL GOT A POINT TOO?
>> YOU GOT A POINT.
>> HIGH SCHOOL ONCE.
>> YEAH.
>> WE WILL SEE.
>> MY QUESTION IS, OBVIOUSLY, WE
HAVE WATCHED YOU SINCE I DON'T
KNOW HOW OLD US WAS WHEN WE GOT
AN OPPORTUNITY TO FIRST GET
INTRODUCED TO YOUR FAMILY BUT WE
HAVE WATCHED YOU GROW UP.
WE LIVE IN THIS WORLD RIGHT NOW
WHERE WE LIVE IN A CYBER
BULLYING WORLD AND EVERYBODY HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT AND
SAY WHAT THEY WANT ABOUT YOUR
GAME OR YOUR FAMILY, WHATEVER.
HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH, LIKE WHAT
IS YOUR GREATEST PERSONAL
STRENGTH?
HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT HAS BEEN SAID ABOUT
YOU AND YOUR FAMILY AND STILL GO
OUT THERE EVERY NIGHT AND
COMPETE AT THE LEVEL YOU COMPETE
AT AGAINST THE BEST TO PLAY THIS
GAME?
>> I FEEL LIKE PRETTY MUCH JUST
MY POP RAISED ME.
NEVER LOSE YOUR COMPOSURE.
KEEP THE FAMILY CLOSE.
WE ALL TALK TO EACH OTHER AND
DON'T LET NOBODY COME INSIDE.
REALLY NEVER CARED WHAT NOBODY
SAID.
>> NEW YEAR.
NEW ME.
SAME ME, THOUGH.
>> SAME ME, THOUGH.
>> LaMELO BALL, YOU ARE THE MAN!
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE RISING
STARS NOD AND WE CAN'T WAIT TO
SEE WHAT YOU DO THE IN LEAGUE
GOING FORWARD.
THANKS.
>> THANK YOU